l'union entre égaux il ne peut y avoir
de travailleurs de deuxième classe
ceux qui effectuent le même travail au
même endroit doivent pouvoir obtenir le
même salaire
[Applaudissements]
la commission a dans ce sens fait des
propositions sur le détachement du
travailleur nous devrions veiller à ce
que toutes les dispositions de l'union
concernant la mobilité des travailleurs
soient justes efficaces et imposer
partout avec le soutien d'une nouvelle
autorité européenne de contrôle et
d'exécution de ces mesures
il est absurde si une autorité bancaire
qui veille à ce que les normes bancaires
sont respectés mais qui n'y pas un
d'autorité et commune du marché de
l'emploi a su rendre la justice sur le
marché intérieur